erschöpft uns über arbeit setzt diese
lehrerin bricht vor ihrer klasse
zusammen
in der region shandong im osten chinas
erscheint die junge frau zur arbeit
obwohl sie sich seit längerem nicht gut
fühlt eine kamera in der klasse zeichnet
auf was dann passiert erst fasst sich an
den kopf dann taumelt sie leicht bis die
kraft sie verlässt uns die lehrerin vor
ihren schülern zusammenbricht
noch während sie fällt das erste kind zu
hilfe auch die anderen schüler reagieren
sofort
ein kollege berichtet später er habe
beim schauen des videos tränen in den
augen gehabt die lehrerin sei sehr
beliebten der schule seit längerem sei
sie allerdings erschöpft und übermüdet
durch die viele arbeit nach einer
infusion gehe es ihr aber wieder besser
mittlerweile konnte sie ihren job in der
schule auch wien aufnehmen